so whenever something Burns oxygen is a  very necessary element that is needed to  enable it to work right but then how  does the Sun burn because of space or a  vacuum there is no oxygen there is  absolutely nothing right but still the  Sun keeps burning and shines so bright  in our Sky how is that so a very  interesting process happens at the core  of the Sun and this process is known as  nuclear fusion now in nuclear fusion uh  too lightweight hydrogen nuclei combined  together to form the heavy helium  nucleus and do you know what happens as  a result of this a tremendous amount of  energy is released okay and this fuels  the sun to burn and shine so brightly  now do you know how long the sun can  burn at this rate and when it will run  out of this amazing fuel comment down  below and for such more insightful  videos subscribe to our Channel your  memories